in terms of your writing how many days a
year to take off projects well I i took
my first vacation in five years to
attend a friend's wedding and the last
vacation five years ago was a wedding
and during that we still worked four
days of the week uh yeah it's like I
don't know if it's our Midwest work
ethic or whatever but you know we do but
it's just I don't know if I want to
though wait I mean really like you've
seen wheat we don't we've always viewed
our presence as a guest seat at the
adults table and if you dare turn and
you dare feel entitled there's the door
that's how folks that we've admired and
watched have have all of a sudden
disappeared for a few years and maybe
they never get a chance to come back the
fight to improve be better better better
is is what Stokes the fire to keep
climbing what that's what it's it's like
I mean we don't I don't think either of
us said we've made what we think is the
perfect movie in nowhere near so we're
trying to make better better better and
that just is what drives us each day you
know is like because every movie based
on the concept or financial restrictions
you're maybe not able to do exactly what
you wanted to do and so you know it's so
you try to figure out different ways
with a more grounded concept that
doesn't isn't necessarily doesn't have
to have one hundred million dollars to
do and so you know we're just always
trying to be better and that's just you
know
I think I'm maybe one day we'll make a
perfect movie that'll get a hundred
across the board around tomatoes and
whenever you're asking like we're done
but you know any short of that keep
organ although the collection currently
has a 100 on rotten tomatoes yeah don't
check back tomorrow go jumping huh
you